I have to say it again, it's just so great
to be here in New York.
It's great to be here in New York.
(audience laughing)
I'm sorry.
Does someone have a problem?
Uh, does somebody have a problem?
(audience laughing)
Sir, what is your deal?
I dunno, what's your deal?
(audience laughing)
You don't have me fooled, O'Brien.
Don't have you fooled?
What are you talking about?
Oh it's great to be here in New York.
Like you're really here, come on?
(audience laughing)
Of course I'm here.
Yeah right!
I know the truth, unlike the rest of these people.
Wake up!
TV's a bunch of lies.
You're not in New York, you're back in some fancy
Hollywood sound stage pretending to be in New York.
(audience laughing)
That doesn't make any sense.
Where do you think you are right now?
Oh, I'm in New York, the greatest city in the world!
(audience cheering)
[Conan] Wait a minute.
We got bridges, we got roads.
You're saying, but I'm in California?
Yeah.
Even though we're in the same room?
It, looks, like we're in the same room,
thanks to your fancy Hollywood CGIF trickery.
No, no, it's just called CGI.
It's not CGIF.
CGIF.
Computers got eye balls, fool.
(audience laughing)
So stupid.
What if I invited you on stage?
Wouldn't that prove to you that I'm really here,
in New York?
Would that prove it to you?
Maybe, maybe.
[Conan] Come on up!
Alright. Alright.
(audience cheering)
Alright!
Yeah, yeah!
Never met a hologram before!
I'm not a hologram!
Whoa, you're real!
Yeah, yeah.
You convinced?
I owe you all an apology.
Kinda called you stupid.
You real?
Yeah I'm real.
Whoa!
I feel like an idiot I'm really sorry.
It's okay, it happens.
Happy for you.
I got an idea.
You wanna go back stage, hangout in the green room,
with the cast of Daddy's Home 2.
They're all here.
You want to?
Lithgow is here?
Yeah
Ferrell?
Yeah.
Really?
Go ahead.
Be our guest, get everybody out.
Hey guys!
I'm comin!
(audience applauding)
(audience laughing)
What the hell?
(thud)
(audience applauding and cheering)